and minimalists hello everybody welcome
to the minimalist podcast where we
discuss what it means to live a
meaningful life with less
my name is Joshua Fields Milburn I am
Ryan Nicodemus and together we are the
minimalists welcome to episode 170 we're
back baby indeed it took February off
from this main feed yeah we accomplished
all of our dreams my back healed up a
little bit I mean oh my goodness you're
still seated today yeah and some of my
problems have healed I've learned more
about my my gut issues maybe we'll talk
about that today on the maximal episode
but we've got some questions we need to
dive into our first question oh by the
way today we're talking about
subtraction yeah
it's almost spring Ryan and spring
cleaning is in the air it's it's funny
like even for me even now as a
minimalist spring cleaning is something
that it's that time where it's like oh
the beginning of the year you start
thinking about the stuff beginning of a
month you might think about the 30-day
minimalism game but for spring it
because there is that a sort of societal
expectation of spring cleaning that's
become a meme yeah and so we're gonna
talk about subtraction today and that
might mean subtraction of stuff but it
also might mean subtraction of habits or
relationships and some other things
we're going to talk about today our
first voicemail is from Kelly in
Illinois I'm a big talker I'm also a
huge introvert but I kind of wanted to
know how to talk less and be more of a
listener regardless if it be having a
normal conversation telling a story or
even asking questions I tend to probably
too much and I would like to kind of
simplify and keep my words short and
sweet and simple but it's really
difficult for me to do that because I
love to talk so much and that's probably
just part of my personality so I just
wanted to know how I can add minimalism
to when I talk to people man Ryan
so Kelly this is a good question because
it's not when we get that often but it's
such an important question sure I think
yeah she said some things that really
stood out to me in her question itself
yeah sometimes what the question doesn't
say reveals more about the question you
know what I'm saying I think so yeah she
said I have two quick questions for you
guys
and there was one question she was she's
anticipating speaking more right and
that that's her thing she's like I'm
anticipating a book when all I really
need to put out there is a blog post or
an essay right or a tweet yes sometimes
140 characters can be far more
meaningful what's the UH who was it uh
Mark Twain right podcast Shaolin looking
over Foshan he said I'm sorry this
letter so long I didn't have time to
make it shorter and in her question she
said some things here I'm a big talker
but I'm also a huge introvert I think
that was possible
I well here's the thing I don't think
she's necessarily an introvert maybe I
don't know if you've done the
myers-briggs maybe you are but
introversion extroversion is a spectrum
now you and I I'm extreme introvert
you're extreme extrovert that just means
that's where we get our energy from it's
from either being alone get recharge you
get recharged from being around other
people however it that doesn't say
anything about social competence yeah I
can be around people just fine in the
sense that I I can interact with them
however there are some extroverts that I
know they need to be around other people
I said they get charged but they're not
that socially competent my former spouse
was another form of that she's very shy
she's a pretty extreme extrovert but you
remember Carrie she's pretty shy around
people that she doesn't know and I think
maybe Kelly's in the situation now where
maybe she's not an extreme introvert
maybe she's an extrovert and she's just
shy around other people it's possible
man I mean I know for me it's uh it's
hard for me to like not interrupt people
and it's hard for me to like keep up
with the conversation sometimes and it
it for me I guess applying minimalism to
those conversations and to those social
interactions I think about how you know
what it takes to be a good listener I
with the biggest piece of advice I've
ever gotten about being a good listener
is not thinking about the next thing
you're going to say so I was was my and
this was a few years ago and we were
talking and and I was expressing this to
her I'm like man I really wish
that I could be a better listener I just
you know I don't know know what it is
like I try to pay attention she was like
Ryan I think like you always got this
look in your eyes like you're always
thinking of the next thing you're gonna
say right exactly yeah it's but she's
absolutely right and that's that's just
one small thing but also um mirroring so
like repeating things back to people
because really when you're having those
social interactions man what do people
want they want to be understood they
what they want to know that you are
respecting them that you are respecting
their preferences and the way you can do
that is is by mirroring by being a good
listener but I would say to Kelly when
you talk a lot to people complain about
it because maybe maybe people like
hearing her talk you know yeah reminds
me of something I remember we were
sitting with with Patrick Rome in
Minneapolis at a coffee shop and several
of our friends were there
and it's one of those situations I
really enjoy Patrick he was on one of
our podcast episodes back in the 80s I
think was number 84 waitwhat back in
that we were doing this podcast on a
cassette recorder in the 80s back on
Warren Street no and I would I realized
was someone like him is I enjoy
listening to him more than I do
participating in the absolutely the
talking right because I feel like I'm
he's not that much older than us but
like he has this sort of empirical
wisdom that he has gained from a
different life from ours and through me
I feel like I can almost soak that in
villa's osmosis the key there is then
what find out what serves the greater
good the most yeah and in that scenario
it's like me listening is serving a lot
more than me interjecting yeah and then
sometimes when you and I do events well
if we do like a little VIP event
beforehand there's like 50 people out of
the thousand people who show up they did
a little VIP thing we're supposed to be
talking ninety-eight percent of that
time right yeah and if we were just
there listening to other people mana on
a bit I don't think that would serve the
greater good for the audience it might
help that one person out of the 50 but
for the 50 who were there it makes more
sense for us to be the the Patrick roan
of that situation so what you're saying
is Kelly needs to really look at what is
appropriate within the conversate
sometimes it's totally appropriate to
ramble and and maybe need to vent and
maybe if you had a friend who you can
vent to that's totally appropriate but
yes sometimes we need to we do need to
just you know kind of stop and listen I
think it's a push in the pool and that's
in that stopping and listening but then
also pulling the conversation forward
through through your own through through
your own dialogue and for me I'm
thinking back to the most meaningful
conversations that I've had it's it's
never the ones that I anticipate are
gonna be the most meaningful right it's
I had in fact I had coffee with Jamie
kill Steen last week you know Jamie
kills Dino he is a comedian he's been on
a bunch of like shows and stuff sweet is
right yeah yeah absolutely yeah he was
saying something to you like I was
talking about you always want to do
stand-up comedy
but he's and he's actually helping some
folks work on Santa come he's a really
well-known comic but he had some pretty
significant life changes over the last
few years he was sort of excoriated
online in this particular community he
was in I won't go into the details you
can listen to the the conversation he
did with Joe Rogan Sean I think put a
link to that in the show notes but
anyway I was having a conversation and
what I was rila I was learning stuff
from him but then he was also learning
from me and and it was it was very
similar to our relationship with
symbiotic in a way but also like mint or
minty and then those roles flip and it's
mentor mentee just was in the span of
five minutes I can be the mentor in the
five minutes later I'm the mentee if you
find those conversations for me that's
the place from which I grow the most
went absolutely all of a sudden you look
up and you're like oh my gosh 90 minutes
or II gotta come by and I know you have
to leave because I can't wait to
continue this conversation there are
other conversations where it's like
we're only three minutes into this it
feels like three hours so how's the
weather
okay the small talk it's funny I really
tried to not talk about the weather and
let's just like really app but uh but
but to keep this conversations like if
you if you are having a conversation you
want to keep a conversation going for me
like I will start to just ask like some
good probing questions about that other
person because people again they like to
share their preferences they like to
share
their values they like to they like to
add their two cents the things I mean I
was talking to Colin the other day a
couple days ago we had a phone call yeah
we were just talking about yeah Colin
right you know exile lifestyle he he
gave me a call he's coming into town
here in the next few weeks and it was
one of those conversations were like you
know we were just kind of planning on
you know what we were gonna do when he
was in town and then an hour and a half
later I'm like dude I'm we're like if
we've been talking for an hour and a
half we've got a leg hang up but uh but
I mean it was a really nice it was
really nice dialogue we were just you
know talking about different different
issues or different perspectives just
different things that are impacting the
world right now and it was it was a very
meaningful conversation but but I think
that's what it comes down to is Kelly
what is it what is it that you can do to
make the the conversation most
meaningful and I think if you're focused
there I think if you're constantly
asking that question you can get that
this this answer to your question of how
do you how do you know where to talk
less how do you know when to talk more I
think I'm gonna wrap up Kelly's question
with a few practical tips as well so the
thing that has helped me in the past
become a better listener because I too
struggle with listening and I'm not a
world-class listener but people often
think I am because I do a few things one
is I pause especially when I'm about to
say and or but any of those sort of
conjunctions because what am I trying to
do there I'm just trying to keep the
sentence going I didn't you and I were
talking about this last week I didn't
sufficiently hammer home this point so
I'm going to batter you over the head
with it three different ways now yeah
instead of saying but or and I just
pause for a second and then quite often
that room that space creates the space
for someone else to interject or
sometimes it gives me enough space to
have that dramatic pause and and to keep
going
also when you're communicating with
other people realize there are two
different types of communication I
talked about this in my how to write
better writing class when you're writing
but it's the same for talking as well
there's expressive communication it's
the things I do with my body doing these
body movements it's the facial
expressions etc I'm trying to to express
something but then what am I trying to
commune
Kait as well so I'm trying to
communicate facts expressions or sort of
the emotions good conversation contains
both types of communication expressive
and communicative absolutely and then
finally our friend Nate Greene who was
on the pot get the breakups episode of
the podcast he he had a friend who said
who's really quiet most of the time and
Nate was was sort of talking him about
this because he found that his friend
was a good communicator but he was very
quiet and his friend said this he said I
speak only when it adds more value than
silence yeah and can you imagine
aspiring toward that yeah
because silence is valuable Kelly I love
this in your copy of our book essential
it's an essay collection with a hundred
and fifty different essays about
intentional living twelve different
areas of intentional living everything
from stuff and minimalism to success and
priorities but there is a chapter in
there about relationships as well and
how we interact well with others and I
think you'll find value in that podcast
Sean if you give reach out to Kelly
please send her the book version of that
or the eBook version if you want or if
you enjoy our podcast you'll also like
the audio book version of essential
essays by the minimalists all right Ryan
before we move on to our lightning round
looks like we have Sean has five more
voicemail questions today we're gonna
answer on our maximal episode this week
on patreon I also want to talk to you
about some personal stuff that that
happened to me that I think relates a
little bit to Kelly's question we just
we just answer it as well in the
meantime we'd love to hear what you have
to say so if you have a comment or tip
about subtraction leave us a voicemail
for zero six two one nine seven eight
three nine or email a voice memo to
podcast at the minimalists comm where
our favorite comments and tips on a
future episode and stay tuned to the end
of this episode for this week's listener
comments and tips and here's a pro tip
for you write down your question before
you call in it'll make things easier for
everyone especially for podcast Sean but
you'll feel better about your question
to Ryan what time is it you know what
time it is it is time for our lightning
round will we answer questions from
social media we're on Twitter Facebook
and Instagram at the minimalists during
the lightning round this is where Ryan
and I each do our best to answer every
question with just a short shareable
less than 100
40 carat the response we also put the
text of these minimal Maxim's in the
show notes so you can copy and share our
pithy answers on social media if you'd
like and now you can find all of our
quotes in one place thanks to our good
friend Jessica Lynn Williams minimal
Maxim's column is that place all right
Ryan are we are we ready for the first
question let's do it let's do it it is
from Amy do you feel it's as important
to let go of obligations in the form of
family and friends who no longer serve
you as it is to let go of stuff man some
I don't have a short answer for this I
don't have a pithy one although I guess
this is somewhat pithy but it's not
something I would tweet but I think
maybe the name is looking at this
question looking at this topic looking
at the situation without the full view
mm-hmm and the thing I would say is if
your expectation is to be served that is
a poor expectation now every every
relationship there if you're removing a
relationship from your life it's not
just because you aren't being served by
it but sometimes it might be because you
can't serve the relationship and so I
think the better question is what can I
give to this relationship and then what
am I getting after I figure out what I
can what I can give without the full
expectation of receiving I totally
understand well my pet the answer is
this it's pretty simple minimalism is a
tool to help you say yes to that which
is most important and meaningful and
what I mean by that is is to look at
things that are or are not serving you
that it's not a question of whether or
not it's doing something for you really
is it creating a meaningful experience
is that helping you create a meaningful
experience for yourself or for that
other person stands out to me when you
say that is the word well-being because
and when I think about about the things
I have in my life or the the
relationships in my life does it add to
my overall well-being and if I'm just
being served I mean think about that
you're served when you go to a
all-inclusive resort yeah you're just
constant and it's it's great for a day
or two days but if you were to do that
for two years you would feel
infantilized where everyone is just
bring
new towels and that that's not
meaningful that doesn't help your
well-being long-term and so in order for
something to help your well-being maybe
you need to be able to give to it and
then also be able to get something from
that yeah man
you gotta get a look at that us box all
right next question is from the optimal
roadmap how can I determine whether
something is an obligation I often feel
obligated to do a lot of things I
shouldn't have to this is an important
question the obligation thing yeah you
and I have had to remove some
obligations from our plates recently our
collective plate because you broke five
vertebrae on your back and that's a
problem and that made you lay up in bed
for several weeks because that's pretty
much all you could do and with me and my
gut issues of a fungal overgrowth
bacterial overgrowth and that has
created some significant you know when
your guts broken your brains broken and
so I've had some issues with depression
because of that and and realizing that
those two things are connected I also
realized that you know what these are
obligations that I am I have to set down
for a period of time it's weird though
when we have obligations the question
them to ask is like who who told you you
had to do this do you feel obligated
uh-huh or did you over commit yourself
and you've made yourself obligated at
this point right and the thing is who
told you to do this usually it's it's me
who told me to do this right
well my 50 answer is walking toward the
right obligations allows us to leave
behind obligations that don't serve us
so we talked about relationships and
serving us but here the the the
obligations serving us I think in order
for it to be an obligation it should
serve us sure some way otherwise you
know man I if you if you show me your
calendar I'll show you what your
priorities are right if you look at my
calendar those are my my priorities it's
not what I say I do with the day but
those are also my obligations so those
better serve me they've been our add to
my well-being other way otherwise
they're just getting in the way of my
well-being absolutely my pity answer is
this being a minimalist doesn't free you
for meaningful obligations so I guess
what I'm what I'm thinking about here is
there are even some obligations I don't
want to do but I still have to do we got
to pay taxes I mean that's like the you
know it's taxis and that's the one thing
that stands out right now I really wish
we didn't have to get all the paperwork
together even though we have a CPA
there's still a lot of prep work that
goes into sending that information
together texting absolutely with the CPA
so you can I guess what would you call
that chipping away at an obligation
maybe but if you can't remove the whole
thing how do you make it how do you
remove some of the friction yeah it's
like a four hour work week or work week
approach yes and Ferriss approach
totally agree all right let's move on to
our added value portion of the show Ryan
this is where we talk about the things
that have added value to our lives
recently I wrote down the show escape at
Dannemora because it's hard to get me to
finish a TV show but that's not what I'm
going to talk about today I'm calling an
audible at the last moment I've been
listening to this album by a guy named
st. John and I don't know how to
describe it it's a contemporary hip-hop
R&B but not really it's almost like a
mixture of singer/songwriter and hip-hop
and R&B it's kind of like if you took
the weekend or what Drake used to do and
but evolved it to 2019 it's really good
his it's his first album it's called a
collection one and in fact Shawn maybe
we can in this episode by playing them
out with one of my favorite songs from
that which is called selfish its man it
really it really resonates with a former
version of myself but yeah check that
song out at the end of this Ryan what
are you what's happening adding value to
your life
that reminds me before I go to my edit
value' reminds me of the Miko concert
just one two she has so many songs about
her consumption habits it's so good and
it just reminds me of like you know my
days of yesteryear I'm gonna recommend
that New Yorker presents man this is on
Amazon Prime so Amazon Prime like it's
convenient with the two-day shipping and
I mean in LA you get like same-day
shipping some time you know you get some
discounts here there yadda yadda yadda
but I never really took advantage of the
prime video that they have there cuz you
know I'm usually going to Netflix if I
want to watch something but dude there's
the show called The New Yorker presents
and to my surprise rob bell he's an
episode number 8
like a nice little like 1012 minute
segment on his life in kind of his
history and it's just an approach that
this the magazine takes you've got
you've got satire you have some
nonfiction you have some reality it's a
little bit of everything I highly
recommend it if X and I get our New York
or usually on fries it shows up in the
mail we'll spend Saturday and Sunday
just sort of flipping through and
reading things to each other I really
enjoy that so I'll take a look at the
show as well let's move on to right here
right now where we talk about what's
going on in the lives of the minimalists
so home tour we have my home tour over
at YouTube and Jordan tells me that
thing is doing well people find a lot of
value in it and that's good it was about
five minutes long but you get to see
into our lives l was there and Becks is
there and you could see some of Ella's
toys and me doing pull-ups and all kinds
of other it was actually here did you do
like a million pull-ups well that was on
the patreon episode in the home tour on
patreon and civil and yeah it was 239
I've been told yeah okay talk about that
more that is interesting that someone
sat there in counted it took me about 20
seconds to realize what was happening
because like Jordan did such a good job
of taking like camera we're really
impressed for 20 seconds for 20 seconds
I was like why why is this Josh doing
pull-ups so much and then I just
realized it was on this loop and I was
like oh that's hilarious
yeah it's but we did the full house tour
you can check it out and I also talked
about some of the rationale behind some
of the things that we brought into our
into our home Ryan and I are working on
a new book and a new film and this is a
bit of a teaser I can't really talk a
whole lot about it right now because
we've set them on this plate that we're
getting back to really soon it's not
abruptly yes Lewton free film gluten
free book yes yeah so details come in on
that but if you're on our email list
you'll be the first to to hear about
that or we'll also talk about on the
podcast in the future and then we're not
doing any tour stops in the near future
but our friend Colin Wright who you just
mentioned is going to be in LA yeah so
I'm going to give the intro at that talk
on March 16th and I might even be at his
Minneapolis tour stop this summer
because back
does 4th of July in in Minneapolis where
her family is so if that code that
corresponds with me being out there but
you can find details to that here's what
here's what I'll say the LA event I
think it's only 120 seats so as soon as
you're hearing this if you want to go to
that I don't make any money from telling
you this but I really support Colin go
to it just be coming toward comm that
will sell out as soon as we mention it
it's in Hollywood okay yeah so it's the
Met Theatre I think it's called but all
the information is that be coming toward
comm he's doing 26 cities in total so
you can check him out he's talking about
minimalism and things but also learning
you know his podcast is called let's
know things and Ryan this week we have
five more questions about subtracting
certain relationships from our lives
about letting go of sentimental items
about minimalism for parents
grandparents and teens I think those
were two or three different questions
and then about simplicity for artists
visual artists in particular here but
we'll just talk about simplicity for
artists and more if you want to hear our
answers to those questions you can
listen to this week's maximal episode
available exclusively on patreon that's
right you're currently listening to our
weekly minimal episode but each week
Ryan and I record an entirely different
long-form a maximal episode on the
minimalists private podcast which gives
us the private space we need to talk
about our flawed habits our family lives
our struggles our relationships our
emotions and our insecurities without
fear of judgment or public ridicule also
Ryan I think Bex and I had our first
fight this week in four years Wow
I just want to talk about that a little
bit as well because I learned I learned
some stuff maybe about subtracting some
emotions or some expectations from
something so wait you have emotions Wow
what wait a minute who are you what have
you done with Josh Milburn no I
subtracted her emotions Oh perfect it's
all fine now that we've gotten rid of
her emotions they're removed surgically
no but yeah so well patreon is also the
best way for us to fund this podcast
keep it 100%
advertisement free so when you subscribe
to the minimalist private podcast on
patreon you'll also receive a personal
link to our maximal episodes so that
they play in your favorite podcast app
you also get access to our entire back
catalog of more than a hundred private
podcast episodes find all the details
and all the good stuff and including an
additional podcast episode every week
over at the minimalists dot-com slash
support Ryan what else you got for us as
always I just want to encourage people
to read more and get informed and now
here are some voicemail comments and
tips from our listeners hello this is
Tina from Kansas I'm calling in response
to the person who wrote into patreon
about their kids wanting name brand
clothes
Nike shirts and shoes and stuff like
that and I wanted to share what I do
with my kids I kind of try to follow the
Dave Ramsey method I have two kids in
junior high right now in elementary
school they could care less about name
brands and in middle school they're very
concerned about it and as a high school
teacher they tend to care less about it
again but there's something about junior
high anyway I don't want to deprive them
of that but I also can't afford it so
what I do is explain the value of a
dollar to them I tell them how much I
make how much dad makes how much minimum
wages per hour what our mortgage is you
know that it costs money to flush the
toilet and buy food and turn on the
lights and all of those things trying to
break it down for them so they can kind
of see the big picture of why it's silly
to spend $50 on the t-shirt for a kid
that's going to grow out of it so I have
them work for it just like Dave Ramsey
said instead of giving them an allowance
like at the end of the week or whatever
it's important to pay them immediately
so I have one dollar bills
stashed in my house and if I need
something done and I don't want to do it
vacuuming the floor or shovel the
driveway you know I tell them I'll give
them five bucks to shovel the driveway
and they'll have to do it ten times if
they want to get enough money saved up
to buy a $50 t-shirt but that
up to them and then they usually say nah
forget hit thanks hey guys it's Leah
from Portland Oregon I just wanted to
share something that I've been kind of
noticing just with a lot of clothes that
people own and it's what I call the
laundry challenge so many of us have
enough clothes to get through probably
multiple months without doing laundry
but then it comes down to certain
objects that force us to do on during a
run out of pants or your run out of
socks so I've been just kind of trying
to see how long I can go without doing
laundry and it kind of forces you to try
out clothes that you normally wouldn't
in your closet since we often end up
just wearing the same things so that
kind of gives you a chance to one use
the stuff that you have been just kind
of letting sit around and to kind of
gives you a chance to see is this
something that I really want to hold on
to joy like this you'll want to use this
more or is it something that I just need
to let go of and give away and then it
also makes us realize the things that
maybe we need so maybe you were kind of
seeing a sweater that we want to buy but
we really don't need it what we need is
more socks and underwear to get through
another week of laundry to kind of
conserve water and conserve our time so
I've been noticing I feel like I can get
through you know about a week and a half
and I'll reuse I'm not really wearing
that many jeans or sweaters since I tend
to rewear stuff but then I quickly run
out of socks and underwear and
essentials that you normally don't think
of but are sexually super important
another tip is I often reuse clothes
like I was saying earlier like jeans and
sweaters and tights things that aren't
necessarily dirty or maybe you put it on
for a second and then you changed a
couple hours later and so I just kind of
have like a soft cloth laundry bin that
I put next to my actual hamper in my
closet and if I have a pair of jeans or
sweater that I just wore and I knew I'm
probably gonna wear it again before I
wash it and I'll just throw it in that
bin and that way it's not just sitting
on the floor but then I don't have to
put in my hamper it's one of those kind
of in-between where you don't want to
wash
it but you don't want to put it away
it's not really clean but it's not
really dirty and I feel like it just
kind of helps keep my space organized
and kind of helps me know where all my
clothes are and just so I can just grab
my favorite sweater and run out the door
and it's all taken care of
another kind of clothing related tip is
if you have a special occasion coming up
Rent the Runway com can be really
helpful I've had about seven weddings
this year that I've had to go to and I
don't feel like I need a new dress for
every single occasion but I also feel
like I don't want to wear the exact same
dress to seven weddings especially
because there are different seasons and
some are inside and outside but I also
don't want to buy a million different
outfits and spend hundreds of dollars so
I'm looking to rent the runway you can
rent you know high quality designer
clothes without actually purchasing them
so you're kind of decreasing the need
for multiples of these dresses to be
made and sold instead you can just rent
one in your size and return it when
you're done and then someone else can go
ahead and use it all right right
hi Ryan and Josh this is Kim calling
from Portland Oregon and I was just
calling in regards to a question from a
listener named Kimberly from the food
episode a while back on organic
vegetables and fruit at affordable
prices
I just wanted to recommend imperfect
produce to her and it's available in
certain areas but it's growing local
wildfire so I suspect it will be popping
up in other cities and they offer both
organic and conventional produce that is
Lee and won't be accepted by a grocery
store so it is much cheaper than buying
the same vegetables and for at the local
local grocery store buy ugly I mean it's
usually just really big really small or
it has some slight scarring etc the
surface also helps to avoid food waste
and puts money in local farmers pockets
for items that would normally go in the
garbage they deliver weekly or bi-weekly
for a small fee the low cost of the
produce makes up for the delivery fee by
far I get a giant box of produce weekly
for about 17 dollars and if I purchase
the same amount of food at the local
grocery store not Whole Foods it would
cost at least $50 I would highly
recommend it if it is available in her
area I also donate 5 pounds of food to
local shelters if you post a photo of
your ugliest piece of produce that week
on Facebook or Instagram and they have
several cities listed on their website
at imperfect produce calm thank you
alright Joe that's it for now you can
comment on this episode at youtube.com
slash the minimalists and if you want
our show notes in your inbox sign up for
our email list over at the minimalists
com just enter your email address at the
top we'll never send you spam because
that stuff's gross but we will send you
our show notes as well as our simple
Sunday emails each week and if you leave
here today with just one message we hope
what's this love people and use things
because the opposite never works thanks
for listening y'all we'll see you next
time oh and by the way here is st. John
his song is selfish unless you're
watching this on YouTube then click on
Ryan's face right here we'll see you
and minimus